قد لا يبدو الأمر كثيرًا ، لكن هذا هو
المكان الذي بدأت فيه هزيمة بوتين في دونيتسك
جائزة من القرن الماضي ربما ، لكن
القطارات والمسارات لا تزال هي الطريقة التي تشن بها روسيا
الحرب اليوم ،
ما تبقى منها الآن قد تحرر من
روسيا جيدًا ، هذا ما كان يدور حوله كل
شيء.  مركز السكك الحديدية المركزي هنا الآن
في أيدي الأوكرانيين ودمره
القتال وكان هذا جزءًا أساسيًا
من احتلال روسيا
لدونيتسك ولهانسك ، فإن القلق بالنسبة لموسكو هو التأثير الضار الذي
سيحدث لقواتهم طوال الطريق إلى  على
الحدود الروسية
على أطراف البلدة ، لم نر أي علامة على
وجود مئات الأسرى الروس أو
القتلى الذين كان من المتوقع أن يتبعوا
هزيمة موسكو الاستراتيجية هنا
ولا داخلها ، إما
ربما تم نقلهم بالفعل
بدلاً من الصمت المطلق
فقط الدراجات المحلية في الشوارع
عدة  أخبرنا السكان أن الروس
غادروا بالفعل بأعداد كبيرة يوم الجمعة
وغادروا في الليل وفي النهار
قال الناس إنني لم أر ذلك بنفسي
لكنهم قالوا إنهم جلسوا  كانت حقائبهم تتساقط أثناء قيادتهم للسيارة
وهم يركضون
بهذه الطريقة ، سيكون توقيتًا رائعًا أن
تهرب روسيا من لو مان في نفس
الساعات التي كان فيها بوتين يوقع أوراقًا
تعلن هنا أراضي روسية
وعقد تجمعًا في الميدان الأحمر
قصة مماثلة في.  الإدارة المحلية
حيث العلامات الوحيدة
المتبقية لروسيا هي الأعلام المحروقة
التي هربوا منها دون أن يقولوا كلمة
لأي شخص يقول
إنه كان سيئًا لا عمل لا غاز ولا قوة
لا شيء
لم تعمل المتاجر كما لو لم يكن هناك أحد
متخلف عن الأنظار  الصمت هنا بصرف النظر عن
القصف العرضي ونيران الأسلحة الصغيرة
، وقد دمر الكثير من هذه المدينة
تمامًا الكثير من السكان المحليين الذين
أخبرناهم بالمغادرة عندما بدأ الأوكرانيون
نحوها ، ولكن الآن مجرد هذا
الشبح المطلق في مكان يمثل مثل هذه
الاستراتيجية  هزيمة
لإطلاق النار من روسيا في المسافة التي يشعرون فيها بالتوتر ،
قد يُترك بعض الروس
خارج ما تبقى من
المحكمة ، التغيير المستمر والعنف أكثر من
اللازم بالنسبة لبعض زوجها.  ألقي القبض على
الأجهزة ،
يا إلهي
، لقد توقفت القوات الأوكرانية التي رأيناها
بالفعل عن الاحتفال ، حيث لم يعد
هناك وقت طويل هناك أثناء التنقل مرة
أخرى.
الركض من خلاله يجمعون
الأنقاض لتحترق من أجل الوقود مع حلول فصل الشتاء الذي
غادر في أعقاب انهيار روسيا
هنا بلدة استغرقوا أسابيع لاحتلالها
ولكن ساعات فقط لمغادرة
نيك بايتون والش سي إن إن لومان أوكرانيا